have to cut out the noise all of it the
reason I'm so out there on social is
because it's hard to be so out there and
social most people can't deal with the
heat they don't like when somebody says
they're ugly or stupid we're full of
[__] or a scam artist or they suck or
they're overrated people don't like that
I don't care not because I'm so cool
it's because that person doesn't know me
how can I possibly be upset when Sally
pants 47 is having a bad day besides to
take it out on me because I look too
happy I'm not mad at hate I'm
compassionate to hate but in the same
token 90 of my comments are just little
ghost emojis
and that requires even more tune out
especially the positive noise because
when you get high on your own Supply
it's a wrap